-Thanks for coming on.
I just saw your beautiful
wife backstage.
And today is the 20th
anniversary
of you guys meeting.
-Yeah.
This is the day we met.
20 years ago.
-Isn't that cool?
-Yeah.
-That's awesome, buddy.
-Yeah, it's really weird,
actually.
And the movie "Air"
is opening today,
and we realize that
Michael Jordan wore two numbers
in his career, 45 and 23,
and the date is 4-5-23.
-Holy!
-Isn't it crazy?
-Yes. Come on. That's fun.
-But much more importantly,
it's 20 years
since I met Lucy, so...
-Of course. Yeah. Yeah,
that's much more important.
How is the fam?
Last time we talked,
you were moving everyone
from L.A. to New York.
-Right. Yeah, we did. We --
It was the smartest thing
we ever did, we're loving it.
-You're here?
-Yeah. We're in Brooklyn.
-Yeah!
-Very, very happy. Yeah, yeah.
-You're loving it.
-Loving it. Loving it.
-Let's talk about
the new movie "Air."
I got to see it.
And the reviews are in.
Everyone loves it.
It is fantastic, buddy.
You're so good in this.
Everyone's good in it,
by the way.
-Everybody's great.
I mean, we got just
a lights out cast.
-You really do.
But everything was good.
The script was tight.
You and Ben Affleck, obviously,
everyone loves
you guys together.
You're great.
This was 25 years ago.
-Oh, yeah.
-Look at this.
When you won the Oscars
for "Good Will Hunting."
Look at how happy!
"Yeah!"
-We don't look too excited.
-Yeah. I mean, you got to be --
I mean, what's going
through your --
Remember this? Were you pumped?
-I do. Well, we didn't --
The weird thing about that
was that we, like,
the year before we were
watching it on TV,
it was like -- we had no --
there was no adjustment period
where we went, like,
we just suddenly
were kind of there
in the front row
and Billy Crystal sang a song
with our names in it.
We were like, What is happening?
-What is going on with
our lives?
-Yeah. And we hadn't --
we hadn't talked about
like a speech
or anything like that
because I think, as kind
of lifelong Red Sox fans,
we, you know, you don't
want to jinx anything.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Because I think both of us,
without even talking about it,
we were like...
because later
we talked about it
and it was like I had this
feeling like if I ever said,
Hey, we should think
about a speech,
I would just flash forward
to being like
50 years later
in a bar with him going,
"Can you believe
we practiced a speech?"
-Yeah, yeah.
"That's why we lost."
-"Like we would ever win
an Oscar," you know what I mean?
And then suddenly
we were up there
and I just pushed him
into the microphone.
So he -- and he --
and he just started
kind of babbling and -- and --
and then saying names
of people who had helped us.
And then I was next to him and I
was just screaming the names.
So he would say,
like, "Chris Moore."
And I'd go, "Chris Moore!"
And he'd go, "John Gordon,"
I'd go, "John Gordon!"
-"Gordon! Gordy! Gordy?"
-I was just so happy.
And like --
But that was -- that was
my contribution to the speech.
-Isn't that fun?
-I was like,
the hype man
in the corner, you know?
-Do you still have that passion
and that love of the movies
and the industry?
-Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I mean, well, that's one of the
reasons we started this company.
Ben and I started this kind
of mini studio together,
and this was our first movie
for the studio,
which was really cool.
-What's it called again?
-Artists Equity.
-Yeah, yeah.
Because we're pulling a lot of
the crew members, we're trying
to pull them above the line
and get them paid better.
And, you know,
we kind of feel like --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
-Good for you.
I read about that.
-But it's definitely like
a white knuckle exercise
because we're responsible
for the overages, you know?
So it's like --
-Did you go over budget?
-In three places
we went over budget.
We went over budget,
but in all really good places.
We went over budget
in construction
because we were moving so fast
that we had
the construction teams
working 24 hours a day
to build the sets
because or else we were going to
run out of stuff to shoot.
So we had budgeted 33 days
and we shot this in 24.
So we were moving really fast
without even trying to.
And then we went over
with our -- we had budgeted,
we had allotted a certain
amount of money for cast
and then we got this cast,
so we paid more.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And we were very happy
to pay more.
And then we went over
budget on food trucks.
Because we had food trucks.
-You're a smart guy.
You know how to throw a party.
-Well, we've been doing this
for a long time,
and we know what matters.
People were
coming out and, like,
"There's a Korean
barbecue truck."
-Yeah, that's
exactly right, dude.
It makes everyone happy.
-Yeah, it was really, really --
It was the most fun either of us
have ever had making a movie.
And we've had a lot of fun
making movies.
-I said it before,
but I really mean it.
You're one of the best actors
to do it,
and I love watching you.
It's amazing. You're great.
You're -- I think that you've,
for me,
like, if it was a team,
you're my go to player.
If you're on my team, I go,
just give the ball to Matt.
He'll nail the line.
You go,
"How do you like them
apples," or, you know,
"Ford vs Ferrari," or like,
you know, this stopwatch thing.
You're like, "You want one?
They're Italian."
It's like, yes! You have the way
of delivering these lines
that the crowd goes nuts.
When I watched "Air,"
you had a couple of them.
Everyone just claps.
Like, do you go
into a script going,
"Oh, that line will be my --
that'll be the line I nail"?
-No, no, no.
-You just read it
and just do it.
-Yeah, yeah.
And I mean, you know,
I look at the whole script
and usually
if it's a good script,
then it'll have lines in it.
But I won't kind of plan
it out like that.
I mean, "how do you like them
apples" was kind of a very --
because I'm slamming the number
against the window and all that.
So that definitely felt
like a bigger thing
because it's a bigger thing
in the movie.
But not -- I didn't think it
would, like, sustain, you know.
-Is that the line
that everyone yells to you
when they see you?
-That,
or they just say my name
like the puppet in
"Team America."
-Yeah, that's the other way
to do it too.
-That's the other one
I hear a lot. Yeah.
-Well, when you --
when you get this idea,
you go,
okay, this is a fantastic idea.
This is how kind of the industry
changed, you know?
And a sneaker company
started working with one person.
You created
the Air Jordan brand.
You go, okay, first steps.
We have to talk
to Michael Jordan.
-Yeah.
-I'm assuming.
-Yeah, that was the first thing.
Well, because the script was
great --
-Can't make it without him.
-Well --
Well,
he's not in the movie.
You do realize
And that's all by design because
it's really about --
it's about that deal to make
this shoe
and going back to 1984
and Nike was not Nike
like the Nike we know.
They were like this underdog.
They were in third place
in the basketball division.
-That was, like, already
blew me away.
When that came up, I'm like,
"Oh, yeah, it was Converse" --
-Converse and Adidas,
-Then Adidas and then Nike.
-Yeah. And I'd -- I mean,
I didn't -- I read the script
and I was like, blown away.
I was like, this is all true?
-Yeah>
-So that's I think, you know,
Alex, the screenwriter,
did a really good job
of kind of setting
what things looked like in 1984.
And -- and it just was
really surprising.
-And did you have a meeting
with Michael
or did you make Ben do that?
-I made Ben do that.
-Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Ben, come on. Charm him."
-No, Ben went down
to talk to him,
and actually, that was the kind
of the critical thing,
because we -- out of that
meeting, Michael --
Michael --
Because, first of all,
we said, look,
look, we're not going to do it.
If you don't want us to do it,
we're not going to do it.
And he was like, No, no,
it's a good idea for a movie.
But Ben said, what is --
what's most important
that we get right?
Like, what's most
important to you?
And what he spoke about
were three things.
There was Howard White,
who's an executive that
Chris Tucker plays in the movie.
-Oh, he was great!
-Yeah, he's awesome.
And George Raveling,
who Marlon Wayans plays.
George Raveling
was the first person
who talked to Michael
about Nike.
And then he talked at length
about his mother.
And that was kind of
the critical thing.
It was like, oh, wait a minute,
You know, you know,
to see like Michael,
who's very intimidating dude,
you know, suddenly kind of
be awestruck
and talk about his mom.
And so that was --
so when Ben said like,
"Look, who do you think
we should get to play" --
and before he finished
the sentence, the question,
Michael was like,
"Viola Davis."
-Yeah.
-So, Ben --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-I mean, Viola Davis.
-That's who you go to,
to hit the shot, by the way.
-Yeah, that's who you go to.
Yeah, you give it
to Viola Davis.
-So he called me. He was like,
"I got great news and bad news."
And I'm like, okay.
And he's like,
The great news is I know exactly
what to do for the rewrite.
Like, we got, we're going to put
in George Raveling,
we're going to
put in Howard White,
and we're going to make --
make his mom central to
the whole thing.
And I go, "Great,
what's the bad news?"
He goes, "We have to get
Viola Davis
or we can't make the movie."
-You're like,
All right, all right.
That is -- because
everyone wants Viola Davis.
-That's what I said to Ben.
I was like, that's like saying
you want Michael Jordan
on your basketball team.
-Exactly.
It's a good way to put it. Yeah.
-So we went and we rewrote
and we -- and we really
just kind of drilled down
on that -- on that character
and the dynamic between her
and everybody else in the movie.
-She was phenomenal.
-She's phenomenal.
-She's great.
And it's so well done,
well acted, well written.
Everything was good.
It's funny as well, by the way.
-Yeah.
It doesn't seem like something
that would be a great movie.
It's like, it's about
a shoe deal, like.
But trust me,
it's really -- it's great.
-You're cheering --
-It's a lot of fun.
-By the end -- oh!
No, it makes you feel good.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That's what we used
to call "a feel good movie."
-Feel good movie of the year.
Yeah.
And it's like at the end,
you're like, standing ovation
and clapping, like, "Yes,
I'm so happy for everybody!"
It's wild. You're getting
fantastic reviews.
A lot of critics are saying this
is the best movie of the year
so far,
so congratulations.
-It's only April.
-That's true. Yeah.
-We haven't seen
"Super Mario Bros." yet.
-That's true. Yeah.
We have to wait this weekend.
Matt, your new movie,
"Air," is all about Nike
and Michael Jordan.
So I thought it would be fun to
play a game of basketball
with a twist.
This is beer pong basketball.
Here we go.
Now, here's how this works.
We're going to be
throwing these basketballs
into those giant red cups.
If you make a shot,
your opponent chugs a beer.
First one to make
three shots wins.
Matt, you're my guest,
so why don't you go first?
-All right.
Do I have to hit a particular --
-Not as easy as it looks.
Let me show you how it works.
-Yeah. Watch this.
Oh...
Oh, yeah!
Off the board!
[ Laughs ]
Off the board on that one. Yeah.
That's good.
We can go to commercial right
now, if you want.
-Oh, man.
-Ho, ho, ho, ho!
-I was sure that was in.
I was sure that was in.
-Me too. I was sure.
-This one --
Oh!
-This is brutal.
Am I allowed to get it
in the same one?
All right. All right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-All right.
-Phew. So it's --
this one's for the win.
-This is for the win.
Oh, man.
-Like, "can I get it"
in the one exact one?
Yeah, you did.
You called that shot.
All right,
here we go for the win.
Matt Damon's movie "Air"
is out tonight.
You can go see it in theaters.
-You're saying this
because you think
you're going to hit the shot.
-I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
-What's up?
Boing... boing!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thanks, buddy.
-Come on now.
Matt Damon, everybody.